مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
[موسيقى]
وكاله انباء متابعه للقضاء الايرانيه تقول
بان اعداد قتلى الاحتجاجات تجاوز ال 200
شخص
العربيه ترافقو سفينه بالاسطور الخامس
الامريكي ضمن مهمه للتصدي لتهريب الاسلحه
والمخدرات
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن عن ترحيل اكثر من
10 الاف مخالف لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال
اسبوع
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
انطلاق مشروع لزراعه مئه الف شجره في
منتزه عثمر البري بحائل والعام القادم
موعد للانتهاء منه
مهرجان ساوند ستورم بميدي البيستيوب هيرو
زائرين على مدى ثلاثه ايام ويختتم الليله
نسخته الحاليه
حياكم الله اعلن مجلس الامن القومي
الايرانيه ان التحقيقات كشفت عن مقتل اكثر
من 200 شخص في الاحتجاجات الاخيره التي
اندلعت في البلاد منذ اكثر من شهرين مشيرا
الى ان الضحايا الذين سقطوا خلال
التظاهرات هم من المدنيين وقوه الامن
جانبها اكدت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
ان عدد قتله الاحتجاجات وصل الى
448 شخصا بينهم 60 طفل
هذا ودخلت موجه جديده من الحركه الطلابيه
الايراني اليوم حيز التنفيذ بعد ما اعلن
طلاب عدد من الجامعات الاضراب عن الحضور
بدا من اليوم حتى السابع من ديسمبر الجاري
كما اعلنت ايضا مجموعه شباب الثوره
الايرانيه تنظيمها تجمعات تملا شوارع
طهران للانتفاضه الثوريه على مدى ثلاثه
ايام بدا من الخميس من الخامس من ديسمبر
قبل ذلك افادت وكاله انباء اثنان المدعي
العام الايراني محمد جعفر منتظر لدعاء الى
اغلاق الافتراضي كليا لمواجهه الاحتجاجات
التي تتسع في البلاد واعتبر منتظري ان
اكبر خيانه للحكومه السابقه كانت عصينا
اوامر المرشد فيما يتعلق بالفضاء
السيبراني مشيرا الى وصف المرشد للشبكه
العنكبوتيه بالهجمه الثقافيه كما اتهم
منتظر
مولاوي عبد الحميد الزعيم الروحي للبلوش
حضر خبراء وحقوق الانسان نتبعنا للامم
المتحده من تفاقم مرض النشط السجين اهرج
صدقي وطالبت السلطات الايرانيه بالافراج
عن في اسرع وقت ممكن وقال خبراء الامم
المتحده في بيان ان صديقي يعاني من سرطان
العظم الذي يشكل تهديدا لحياته وقد حرمه
الامن الايراني من بعض الادويه التي يحتاج
اليها منذ توقيفه في اكتوبر لاسباب غير
معروفه حسب ما افاد مكتب الامم المتحده
لحقوق الانسان
من لندن ينضم الى الباحث في شان الايراني
وجدان عبد الرحمن سيد وجدان مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
اريد ان اسال اولا عن تضارب الاحصائيات
الارقام في ما يخص عدد قتلى الاحتجاجات
يعني
400 شخص النظام يتحدث عن 200 شخص وهناك من
يتحدث عن ارقام اكبر من ذلك بكثير اين هي
الحقيقه
تحياتي لك لمتابعي قناه العربيه الكرام
طبعا هذا هو الديدان الايراني ايضا حتى في
احتجاجات
2019 على النظام الايراني بانه عدد القتلى
300 بينما
الرقم الواقعي هو 1,500 فقط يزيد من ذلك
هذه هي التصريحات المتناقضه تجعل الري
العام ايضا منظمات حقوق الانسان ان تكون
متردده في الارقام التي تصلها همم لكن همم
يعني شاهدنا بانه بالفعل هنالك يتناقض
كبير وزير الداخليه الايرانيه همم وحيدي
اشار بانه هنا لك 300 قتيل همم السلطه
القضيه تعلن 200 وايضا التسريبات التي
خرجت من همم وكاله فارس تشير بانه عدد
قتله الاحتجاجات الحاليه يزي عن همم قتل
احتجاجات 2019 بمعنى انه العدد همم
كبير جدا من حيث التضحيات التي قدمت خلال
هذه ايضا هنالك منظمات حقوق الانسان
الاماراتيه 2019 سيد وجدان اذا كنت تتذكر
شيئا منها
عفوا كم كانت اعداد القتلى في احتجاجات
2019 ان كان من ارقام تقريبيه
[موسيقى]
الان نعم نعم نعم الان نتحدث اكثر من 1500
وفقا للتسريبات التي خرجت من وكاله فارس
بعد اا تسريبات التي قامت بها شبكه همم
ريبورد اعلنت بانه في هذا البطن في احد
نقاط اشاره بانه عدد ضحايا الحالي اكثر من
2019 بمعنى وفقا للاحصائيات همم
الايراني بانه عدد القتلى هو يتجاوز ال
1500 لكن ما تم احصائصه حتى الان
462 همم ضاحيه طيب اكثر من 64 طفلا هنالك
ثمان 28 همم شخص ايضا تم اصدار حكم
المحاربه بحقهم من بينهم ثلاثه اطفال دون
السابعه عشر سنوات هذه تعتبر جريمه انه
يتم حكم الاعدام على اطفال همم يعني همم
تاخدهم المشاعر والاحساس طيب ايضا فيما
يخص الحركه الشبابيه التي ستبدا طبعا في
احتجاجاتها في الخامس من ديسمبر تستمر حتى
السابع من ديسمبر اريد ان اتحدث هنا عن
اهميه الشباب في هذه الاحتجاجات عن اهميه
الطلاب ايضا همم كذلك في الاحتجاجات
النظام كيف ينظر اليهم كمحرك في
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها اكثر من مئه
وسبعين وخمسين مدينه ايراني
معدل الاحتجاز معدل الاشخاص الذين يخرجوا
الى الاحتجاجات وفقا للاحصائيه الايرانيه
هو 18 سنه 18 سنه بمعنى انه من شارك في
هذه الاحتجاجات ومن قادها ومن دارها ومن
نسخ غلها هم جيل الشباب ان كانوا طلاب
الجامعات طلاب الجامعات او طلاب المدارس
الثانوي وايضا حتى شارك فيها طلاب المدارس
الابتدائيه ومشاهدناهم هنالك من بعض
المقاطع انه تم استهداف بالقاسم لبعض
المدارس للبنات في همم الدوره الابتدائيه
بمعنى
المحتاجينهم من جيل الشباب وايضا المنفقين
لهذه الاحتجاجات ايضا هم من جيل الشباب
الذين يمتلكون التقنيه والمعلومات والخبره
في مجال همم العمل السيبراني وايضا العمل
في وسائل السوشيال ميديا وهذا ما جعل
مستقره حتى يعني في ما يخص هذا المجال
الفضاء همم طبعا همم نتحدث عن الانترنت
بشكل يعني اعمى دعوه المدعي العام ايضا في
ايران الى اغلاق هذا الفضاء الى حجبه ايضا
كذلك كيف لهذه الخطوه فيما ان تمت ان تزيد
من همم
احتجاجات هؤلاء الشباب نتحدث عن هذه
الاعمار هي من تستخدم الانترنت بشكل مكثف
وربما بشكل
يومي كيف ستؤثر هذه الخطوه على هذا الحركه
الثور الانتفاضه في شوارع طيران وكذلك
المدن الاخرى
اولا ااا ليس بمقدور النظام ان يقوم بهذه
العمليه
لسببين سبب الاول انه النظام لا يملك هذه
التقنيه ولا يملك هذه البنيه التحتيه
للقيام بهذا الامر الامر الثاني انه اييي
اليوم حوالي 12 مليون
يرتزقون ويكتسبون
ويعيشون حياتهم عبره وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في الداخل الايراني بمعنى قطع
الانترنت بشكل كامل انه يشيل
اقتصاد 12 مليون عامل في هذا المجال وهمم
سيضم هذا العدد الكبير والهائل الى
الاحتجاجات ان لم يكونوا موجودين حاليا
الامر الثاني انه اليوم في ظل التقنيات
الموجوده نشهد الصين رغم تعتيمها لاعلامي
وايضا حجز همم والوجود الانترنت الوطنيه
لكن ايضا هنالك الكثير من الصينيين اليوم
يرتبطون مع العالم بسبب التقنيات لذلك
النظام الايراني المتخلف في مجال التقنيات
لا اعتقد ان هو يستطيع منع الشباب في
الداخل اشكرك جزيل شكر على المشاركه معي
في نشاره الرابعه باحث في شان الايراني
وجدان عبد الرحمن
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه رفيع الجروسي انها علاقه الوكاله
تمر بلحظه صعبه للغايه بعد ما علق الطيران
زياره وقت الوكاله لتفقد ثلاثه مواقع
نوويه ايرانيه في نوفمبر الماضي كانت
الوكاله قد خططت للقيام بها واضاف جروس في
مقابله مع صحيفه
الايطاليه ان طيران علقت الزياره واعلنت
انها ستضاعف انتاجها من اليورانيوم المخصب
ثلاث مرات وفقالها
رفقه فريق العربيه الاسطول الخامس في مهمه
بحريه ضمن برنامج الافقي الرقمي المسؤوله
عن الوحده 59 بالبحريه الامريكيه من شانه
سيارات في الخليج العربي لضمان سلامه
البحار والتصدي للتهديدات الايرانيه من
تهريب اسلحه ومخدرات وقرصنه
مع الاصول الخامس
[موسيقى]
فساتين
بحريه بدون قبطان في البحار عبر استخدام
الذكاء الصناعي نركز على وضعه اكثر في
البحر
يمكننا ان نرفع مستوى المراقبه وهو ما
يجعل ذلك اكثر من الجميع
هنا اخي هذا الخليج في الخليج العربي
التحديدات الايرانيه كثيره من قرصنه
وتهريب اسلحه وتهريب مخدرات تحاول الفرقه
59 بالاسطول الخامس ان تقوم بنشر مسيرات
بحريه
وجويه وتحت البحار ايضا لاحباط عمليات
التهريب الكثيره التي تحدث هنا هويه ان
يصل الى نتيجه نهائيه تنهي كل التهديدات
الايرانيه المحتمله في هذه المياه
من الخليج العربي بديع يونس العربيه
من جنيه الباحث السياسي ناصر زهير سيدنا
ناصر مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في النشره
الرابعه من الرياض شهاده هذا التقرير قبل
قليل للزميل البديع يونس يتحدث عن
الاسطوره الخامس كيف يراقب الخليج العربي
ايضا كيف يرصد تهريب الاسلحه المخدرات
يوقف بعض هذه همم
العمليات برايك الى اي ماده هناك خطر دام
وحقيقي في الخليج العربي يلزم موجود مثل
هذا البرنامج برنامج الافق الرقمي
نعم تحياتي لك و لفريق العمل والمشاهدين
يعني داني اعود الى حادثه حدثت في يونيو
الماضي عندما اعلنت القوات البحريه
الامريكيه انها ضبطت 310 كيلو جرام من
الهيروين في قارب صيد قادم من ايران هذه
احدى الشحنات القليله جدا التي تم ضبطها
والاعلان عنها لان هناك كثير من الشحنات
التي تطبدها القوات البحريه المشتركه
للتحالف هذه المنطقه ولا يتم الاعلان عنها
من هنا تاتي اليه او ياتي مؤشر خطا هذه
النشاطات التي تقوم بها ايران فيما يتعلق
في تهريب المخدرات والاسلحه وايضا الى اين
تنتقل هذه المخدرات لان الخطر لا يتعلق
فقط في دول المنطقه بل ايضا يتعلق حتى في
الدول الاوروبيه والدول الغربيه والشيران
فعليا وهذه استراتيجيا الان بدات بانها
بدات تستغل نشاط او تجاره المخدرات سواء
كان من افغانستان او حتى عبر ايران من اجل
التخفيف الاعداء الاقتصاديه الالتفات على
العقوبات ايدها اصبحت استراتيجيه الحرس
الثوري والمنشات التابعه له او العصابات
التابعه له بدلا من ان كانت تكون محصوره
بعصادات تقوم بالتهريب لها ارتباطات في
داخل النظام في ايران ولذلك اذا ما تم
حساب الشحنات بصوره مبسطه تقال لما تم
الاعلان عنه في العام الماضي كنحن نتحدث
عن اطنان من الكوكايين والمخدرات تاتي عبر
هذه ايضا الاسلحه في اطار تهريبها وتصديره
هناك الكثير من التقنيات ايضا ادخل في همم
مهمه المراقبه والاستطلاع في هذا الخليج
كنا نتحدث قبل فتره ليست في بعيده عن
مسيرات بحريه عن زوارق ايضا مسيره كذلك عن
اا حتى مسيرات تتحدث عن درونز همم الوضع
في همم وتراقب الوضع في الخليج العربي لاي
مداهيه قادره على تحجيم هكذا عمليات تهريب
للمخدرات او كذلك للاسلحه او حتى محاوله
سنه ناقلات النفط كما اا حدث خلال الاشهر
والسنوات القليله الماضيه
اذا ما تحدثنا عن تحجيم هذه الاستراتيجيه
وهذه النشاطات هي فعليا قادره على تحديد
هذه النشاطات ويمكن ان تحد منها بشكل كبير
جدا اذا كان هناك اراده دوليه لتنفيذ هذا
الامر وهذه التقنيات بمواجهه التقنيات
البدائيه التي تستخدم
كبير جدا ولا يمكن ان نقول انها كافيه
لمواجهه هذه النشرات بل يجب الضغط اكثر من
اجل مراقبه السواحل من قبل المراكب التي
تاتي من ايران وتعب هذه المنطقه وتقوم
بعمليات تحرير تهريب اذا لم تتحدث عن
الضغط على ايران لايقاف هذه النشاطات ولكن
هذا جيد جدا في اطار هذه العمليات او هذه
التقنيات في مواجهه عمليات التهريب لانها
فعليا كما تحدثنا لا تؤثر على دول المنطقه
ولا تؤثر ايضا على كل دول العالم بما فيها
الدول الغربيه ايضا النقطه الاخرى هي
تفكيك هذه المي وما تقوم به لانه مثلا في
الايام الماضيه كان هناك عمليه كبيره بين
اليوريكول الشرطه الاوروبيه مع السلطات في
الامارات العربيه المتحده فكك كانت عصابه
متخصصه في تهريب المخدرات لها ارتباطات مع
ايران وعصابات كثيره نفس القمر يمكن ان
يطبق ايضا في اليه مراقبه ليس فقط عمليات
التهريب عبر خطوط همم البحر بل ايضا عبره
متابعه هذه العصابات والميليشيات وتفكيكها
والقبض على قضاياها من اجل الحب بشكل
حقيقي من العمليات التحرير المخدرات
والاسلحه التي اصبحت الصاعده بشكل كبير
جدا خلال الثلاثه او الاربع الماضيه
همم سيد ناصر بانها يعني خطوات جيده بانها
خطوه ربما متقدمه لكنك وصفتها بانها ليست
كافيه
لتحجيم هذه النشاطات غير المشروعه برايك
ما الذي تبقى لدى الاسطول الخامس من خطوات
ما الذي يعني يمتلكوا من
وات ربما تضعف او تنهي هذا الخطا همم بخطر
تهريب المثل ال- ال- الاسلحه والمخدرات
كذلك في الخليج العربي
يعني لدى لدينا امرين الامر الاول هو ان
يكون هناك قرار بمواجهه شامله يعني بمعنى
هل نحن نتحدث عن عمليات محدوده ام نتحدث
عن استراتيجيه مفتوحه ويمكن تسخير كل
امكانيات الاسطول الخامس وحتى القوات
الدوليه والقوات البحريه الدوليه المنتشره
في هذه المنطقه اذا كان هذا القرار ويتم
اتخاذه يمكن ان نقول بان فعليا سيحب بشكل
كبير جدا من هذه العمليات ولكن الى حد هذه
اللقطه عمليات مواجهه هي عمليات محدوده
للغايه وليست شامله النقطه الاخرى اليه
التدخل السريع والضغط بكل الاغراض ليس فقط
مراقبه ومحاوله منع هذه المواد التي تنقل
سوء كانت مخدرات واسلحه بل تتبع المصدر
والمتلقي من اجل تفكيك هذه
الاليات هذه الترابطات التي تنقل
الممنوعات والنقطه الاخرى ما يتعلق في
الضغط بالتدخل السريع لان اليه التدخل
البطي للغايه لما تحدث مثلا عن عمليات
القرصنه للاكلات النفط اولياء السفن في
اكثر من مناسبه كان هناك امكانيه لتدخل
قوات التحالف من شكل السريع للغايه ولكن
الخشيه من التوتر او عدم الانجيران
لمواجهه اردت ان اسال عنها سيدنا ناصر
يعني
فيما يخص بط هذه العمليات فيما يخص ايضا
حتى كذلك ربما شراره التوتر التي قد تحدث
جراء اي داهم لهذه الزوارق او اي مثلا
اشتباك قد يحصل في البحر من جانب الحرس
الثوري ان كان موجودا هو بالفعل في هذه
الزوارق او احد اعضاءه وكذلك قوه التحالف
او حتى الاسطول الخامس هنا في هكذا وضع
كيف يتم التعامل معه التقنيه
الى حد هذه اللحظه التعامل التقني دعني
اقول بانه يتم في اليات محدده تقول بانه
لا يجب الانجذار الى التصادم مع ايران
والقوات الحرس الثوري بمعنى التدخل مراقبه
حتى في احدى العمليات كما دورانها تم
مراقبه الحرس الثوري وهو يقوم بالصعود الى
احداث سفن واختطاف يعني هناك تناقض كبير
في هذه الاليه السؤال هنا هناك دائما نظره
في الغرب لانهم لا يريدون الانزلاق الى
حرب او مواجهه مع الحرس الثوري وايران
ولكن هناك نقطتين النقطه الاولى ان الحراس
السوري او اي قوات عسكريه ايرانيه عندما
تقوم بهذه النشطات في الخليج العربي تقوم
بها بنشاطات قوه الدوله ان الشرطه تقوم
بها بنشاطات غير قانونيه وغير المشروعه
وهي ترقى لتكون عمليات قرصنه اذا كانت
وهذا هو الاحتمال عمليات قرصنه يجب ان
تواجه بقوه مهما كانت النتائج النقطه
الاخرى عندما تم قتل القاسم سليماني وهي
الضربه الاقوى التي تركتها اولا 30 عام
الماضيه لم تذهب ايراني الى خيار الحرب
الشامله واعتقد هذه طريقه التفكير التي
يجب ان تتغير بمعنى ان اي عمليه تقوم بها
ايران او قوات تابعه لها او الحرس الثوري
سواء كان نفض او اي سفن اخرى يجب ان تواجه
بقوه كبيره جدا وطبت هذه المجموعه وحتى
وان طروا للتدخل العسكري لان بغير هذه
الصوره ستبقى ايران تمارس عمليات
الابتسامه حركه التجاره العالم
الرابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها ايضا
مهرجان جده السينمائي واصل وفعاليته
ويستقطب نجوما من 46 دوله
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
السعوديه
الاف خلال فتره نفسها الوزاره
15 عاما الى غرامه ماليه تصل مليون ريال
يوصلوا مهرجان البحر الاحمر السينمائيه
الدوليه في مدينه جده فعاليته المتنوعه
حيث دشنا اليوم سوق البحر الاحمر
46 دوله حيث يمنح الحضور فرصه التواصل
والاطلاع على المشهد السينمائي السعودي
بالاضافه الى افضل انتاجات المنطقه
العربيه والافريقيه كما تم اطلاق مسابقه
البحر الاحمر التي ستعرض اهم الانجازات
الابداعيه الافلام في اقسامها الخاصه
للافلام الطويله والقصيره
من جده تنضموا الينا زين زيدان مديره سوق
الانتاج في مهرجان البحر الاحمر مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض خلينا نعرف
اولا
ما هو سوق البحر الاحمر ما الذي سيقدمه
لقطع السينما في السعوديه
السوق اليوم
ديسمبر السوق يعتبر القلب والاساس
المهرجان عندنا مشاريع مختلفه خلال هذه
الايام وعندنا برامج مختلفه نرحب فيها
المحبين الافلام من كافه انحاء العالم زي
ما انتم تشوفوه في الخلف عندنا القلب
المهرجان اللي هو منصه المشاريع عندنا
الاكزيبيشن فيها تقريبا اكثر من 43 شركه
سعوديه عربيه محليه وعالميه متواجدين
لقاءات همم
الاربعه ايام حتى السوق
المشاريع بدؤوا في طرح التقديم للمشاريع
حقهم عندنا 23 مشروع وباذن الله يوم سته
ديسمبر راح نعلن الفائزين في هذا المشروع
البحار الاحمر همم
العربيه كذلك سيكون منصه لاستكشاف صانعي
الافلام كلميني عن هذه النقطتين تحديدا
سيدا زين
احنا الحمد لله شايفين في توسع فيه اهتمام
كبير في همم في السعوديه وفي العالم
العربي احنا في المهرجان بنشجع افلام من
كافه انحاء العالم
ومتخصصين اكثر في افلام من افريقيا ومن
الشرق الاوسط فعندنا مشاريع مختلفه
بندعمهم بطرق مختلفه سواء من صندوق البحر
الاحمر بني عطيه دعم ولا من خلال همم نعرف
المشاريع ونعرف مخرج
[موسيقى]
يعني
مع الشركات كلها المتواجده لان الفرص
كبيره
والمجالات مختلفه فالكل حاضر بيكون متواجد
معنا في المهرجان همم الفرس كبير والفرس
كثيره
بنفتح الفرس لكل احد همم متواجد هناء
يحضر معنا انت تكلمتي على انه عندكم
الكثير من المشاريع الكثير من البرامج قبل
قليل ذكرت بانه لديكم ايضا حتى فرص ملهمه
للمنتجين وش هالمشاريع المختلفه ايش
اختلفت ايضا حتى عن النسخ السابقه وحتى
كيف تطورت
من المشاريع كبرت وصلت الى مهرجانات
عالميه فاحنا بدنا نشجع الكل الفرص كبيره
سواء الدعم كان من المهرجان ولا الدعم من
شركات اخرى
الواحد يقدر يوصل للعالميه باذن الله
عندنا طبعا سلسله من الحوارات والنقاشات
تدور اا حوالين مواضيع مختلفه في مجال
الافلام من من يعني ممثلين كبار في
الشخصيات عالميه بيكونوا حاضرين بحيث انهم
يتواصلوا مع المخرجين والمنتجين
والكتاب همم وتطويرهم الى مجالات مختلفه
المنتجين بالممثلين وكذلك ربما حتى همم
تحت تنظيمكم انتم واشرفكم وبدي احكي على
ورش العمل هذه ايش ممكن تنعكس على سوق
الافلام عندنا في همم السعوديه هلا لمستوا
لها اثر حتى هذه اللحظه من خلال هذه
النسخه او حتى النسخ همم السابق
طبعا يعني
بتمز بطريقه ايجابيه لان زي ما احنا
شايفين عندنا مجموعه كبيره من الافلام
السعوديه سواء القصيره او الافلام الطويله
فنبحث دائما على ال ال المشاريع هذه ونشجع
السعوديين اااه ونشجع يعني المخرجين في
العالم العربي وفي افريقيا بحيث انهم
يقدموا على هذه المشاريع وهذه الفرص عندنا
كان مشروع همم جدا همم اسم المشروع التحدي
صناعه افلام في 48 ساعه عباره عن الاشخاص
يقدروا المبتدئين في مجال الافلام همم
يعملوا فيلم قصير في 48 ساعه كان هذه
السنه النسخه الثانيه واخترنا في الميل من
هذه الافلام بحيث انها تكون موجوده معانا
في المهرجان هذه السنه الواحد حتى لو بدا
بشيء بسيط قدر يوصل انه خلال هذا المشروع
انه يكون معنا في المهرجان في الدوره هذه
معنا الفرس همم جميله ورائعه ونتعم فيها
كل احد اشكرك جزيل الشكر من جده انضمت
الينا زين زيدان مديره سوق الانتاج
بمهرجان البحر الاحمر
وفي حائل بدات قبل عده ايام الخطوات
الاولى لزراعه مئه الف شجره وشجيره في
منتزه عثماره البريه الذي يعتبر واحد من
اهم المشاريع البيئيه في المنطقه ويشرف
عليه المركز الوطني لتنميه الغطاء النباتي
ومكافحه التصحر تفاصيل اكثر مع السلامه
خطوات طموحه بدات بتحويل هذه الصحراء
القاحله الى واحه خضراء على مساحه تقاربو
خمسه ملايين متر مربع يقع منتزه عثمر
البري في منطقه حائل حيث بدات قبل ايام
المرحله الاولى التي تستهدف زراعه 30 الف
شجره
ان تكتمل اعمال التشجير نهايه العام
القادم
مكينه الجمعيه من المركز الوطني لتنميه
الغطاء النباتي ومكافحه التصحر
لاستزراع 50,000 شجر او خمسين الفجيره
بهذا المنتزه طبعا الاشجار راح تكون كلها
اشجار بريه محليه وكذلك الشجره
في منطقه حائل يعتبر واحده من اهم
المشاريع البيئيه في المنطقه خصوصا بعد ان
تظهر نتائج اعمال التشجير خلال الثلاث
سنوات القادمه من هذا الموقع يعتبر من
افضل المواقع اللي موجوده على مستوى
المنطقه من حيث السهوله الوصول الى
اقترابه من المدينه بحيث انه يكون ان شاء
الله مركز سياحيا جاذبا في المرحله
القادمه باذن الله عز وجل لجميع همم فئات
المجتمع بالمنطقه ايش اضف الى ذلك انه هذا
الموقع قريب من مصادر المياه التي ستساعد
ان شاء الله في سرعه نمو هذه النباتات
باذن الله عز وجل باحد الاماكن اللي همم
القائم بالعمل عليها احد مؤسسات المجتمع
المدني وهي جمعيه البيئه بحائل وشوفنا مثل
ما قلنا انه همم الموروثه الثقافي والديني
ورغبه الناس بالعمل وترك الاثر كيف انها
تمكن مثل الممارسات وخلال فتره زراعه
السنويه يشتركوا مجموعه من افراد المجتمع
المحلي ما بين جهات الحكوميه وفرق تطوعيه
بزراعه الموقع فيما يتم توفير المياه من
محطه المعالجه قبل ان يتم ضخها في انابيب
الري بس المراجعه العربيه
الرابعه مستمره في ابعد قليل ايضا
الارجنتين تواجه استراليا وهولندا يتواجه
المنتخب الامريكي في افتتاح دوري 16
لمونديال قطر
حياكم الله من جديد
لكاس العالم بمباريات من العيار الثقيل
على ملعب خليفه الدوليه منتخبه هولندا
والولايات المتحده لمواصله رحلتهما
بنهايات البطوله في مواجهه الثانيه وعلى
ملعب احمد بن علي يلتقي منتخبه الارجنتين
واستراليا
من الدوحه مفاجاه العربيه ليت بزاريه
يلتحق بنا ليت مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض
وطالما احنا من الرياض اليوم فخلينا نسال
عن المنتخب اللي كان معنا في المجموعه
منتخب الارجنتين واللي هو المنتخب اللي
يواجه كذلك استراليا المنتخب ايضا الذي
كان مع السعوديه في مجموعته في التصفيات
الاسيويه كيف تبدو الاجواء الترقب لهذه
المباراه ايضا ويمكن بعنوان مباريات
الدوري ستات عشر ليوم الاثنين
نعم نايف بما انك حكيت من الرياض فان
المباراه ستقام بعد الساعه ونصف الساعه
بين المنتخب الهولندي والمنتخب
الدوحه يعني توقيت الدوحه توقيت الرياض
نعم هذه المباراه الاولى وبدا من اليوم
ستكون المواجهات الكوره الكرويه حاميه
الوطيس من سيخسر سيغادر المونديال طبعا
ومن سيربح سيشق طريقه الى كاس العالم يمكن
على كل حال هنا الاستعدادات على يعني على
قدم وساق الكثير من المشجعين وصلوا ليس
فقط المشجعين الارجنتينيين شاهدنا
السوريين شاهدنا حتى مشجعين من البلدان
الاخرى هون عندنا مثلا شباب
بلجيكا وصلوا منذ خمس ايام همم هو ار يو
سبارتك
سالت مين بتشجعوا اليوم بمباراه امريكا و
بمباراه
الارجنتينل
الحماس في هذه المباراه
والدخول الملعب على كل حال هذول الشباب
طبعا الارجنتين وميسي اكيد هما ميسي
طيب
[ضحك]
ليو ميسي حضرتك
[موسيقى]
والتنظيم اتفضل انت متحمس باول ما شفت
الكاميرا بتحمس تحكي اتفضل من وين انت من
السعوديه اهلا وسهلا حياك الله
دور 16 نعم شو بدك
تحكي كثير متحمس وراء الكاميرا
صراحه واحب البرتغال اليوم شو عندك
استراليا شكرا
انطلقت في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض فاعليه
بسطه التي تشتمل على عروض حيه هوائيه وسوق
مفتوح يستهدف مختلفه شرائح المجتمع
الفعاليه التي تنظمها امانه الرياض تضم
ايضا مناطق مخصصه للاطفال ومواقع الهواه
الرسم بالاضافه الى مساحات مخصصه للالعاب
التنافسيه بين الزوه
ونبقى ايضا في هذه الفعليه فعليه
بسطه من العاصمه السعوديه الرياض ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم اسامه
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في النشره
الرابعه من الرياض خلينا نعرف ما هي ابرز
الفعاليات والمواقع ايضا الموجوده في بسطه
اهلا وسهلا نايف تحيه طيبه عليك ولجميع
الساده المشاهدين بالتاكيد اليوم فعاليه
قصه الرياضه التي تنطمها امانه الرياض
هناك عدد كبير جدا من الفعاليات المتنوعه
هي تركز ايضا على تنميه المشاريع المتوسطه
والصغيره والمنتجات الوطنيه عدد كبير جدا
ايضا من الاركان التي تقدم الماكولات
والمشروبات والازياء والعطورات
والاكسسوارات كذلك هذه الفعاليه تقع في
شارع الامير محمد بن عبد العزيز في طريقه
التحليه وهو يعتبر احد الاماكن تعتبر قلب
الرياض و احدى ارقى الشوارع في العصر
السعوديه الرياض لماذا في التحليه تحديدا
لانها منطقه تجمع جميع سكان الرياض فعاليه
بسطه تقام كل سبت من الساعه الثانيه مساءا
الى الساعه 10:00 مساء في هذه المنطقه وفي
ايضا خبر حصل العربيه اعلنت الامانه الان
ان هناك ايضا اكثر من باصات ستكون موزعه
على كثير من المناطق في الاسابيع القادمه
شبيهه تماما بهذه المنطقه فعاليه بسطه كما
سبقتها فعاليه تجمع جديد من المنتجات
الوطنيه الكثير من فعاليات الفلكلوريه
والفنيه ايضا مناطق للرسم وهواه او هواه
الفن والابداع التصوير كذلك ايضا هناك
مناطق للجميع لكبار السن للاطفال همم
للجميع في هذه المنطقه عدد الاركان
الموجوده همم تزيد عن 200 ركن بجميع
الاشياء التي يحتاجها الجميع طبعا ما هي
فكره ايضا بسطه من اسمها بسطه بمعنى انه
هناك همم مزيج بين الحاضر والماضي في قالب
اجتماعي كبير جدا يخلق تناقم او يخلق
تناقم بين جميع افراد المجتمع في هذه
المنطقه بالتاكيد ايضا روح حيويه كبيره
للزوار والسائحين خصوصا انها تقام لمره
واحده في كل اسبوع امانه الرياض ايضا انها
جهود كبير جدا في تنظيم هذه المناطق ايضا
توسيع مناطق الاركان واعطاء مساحه كبيره
جدا لمن يريد ان يقدم منتجاتها في هذه
المنطقه يعني احنا نتحدث عن همم
200 تقريبا ركن موجوده همم او بسطه موجوده
في همم شارع التحليه وكذلك انت حصلت على
معلومات بانه هتكون هذه البسطه في اكثر من
همم مكان يعني ومن احياء الرياض وفي وقت
متزامن تقريبا من همم كل يوم ثابت من كل
اسبوع اسامه
اي نعم هي هذه البسطه بسط الرياض تقام
بالتزامن مع موسم رياض تحديدا يوم في كل
اسبوع فكره ايضا عندما رات الامانه النجاح
هذا المشروع في هذا المكان الحيوي الكبير
جدا فكرت ايضا انها تنتقل بهذه البساط الى
مناطق اخرى ايضا لتجمع جميع المناطق لانه
منطقه بالتاكيد همم بالسياح والزائرين
وهذا يعني ان هناك ايضا ازدحام فبالتالي
هي ستوتشر في موضوع
تقديم بسطات اخرى في مناطق اخرى ومناطق
حيويه بتركيز كبير جدا هذه فقط المئتين
التي تم انشائها الى الان اما البقيه ما
زالت متاح ايضا لاستقبال طلبات من يريد ان
يقدم منتجاته وايضا من يريد ان همم يذهب
الى منطقه اخرى في البسطات القادمه
للامانه الامانه ايضا تقيم في هذه همم تبث
في هذه المنطقه مباريات كاس العالم كونها
تقع بالجانب واحه الملك سلمان التي همم
تحمي شاشه كبيره جدا تنقبات كاس العالم
وكثير من الفعاليات ايضا الامانه اعلنت ان
هناك الفنيه
الحفلات الغنائيه الكثير من الوصلات
الشعريه ايضا ستكون موجوده خلال همم
مساءات السبت من كل يوم السبت في كل اسبوع
في هذه البسطه وصلت الرياض ايضا هناك جزء
كبير جدا من الحيويه يعني الناس لما تيجي
تخش طيب تاخذ وتشتري وتروح هذا يعطيها نوع
من
الانسيابيه في هذا الموضوع طيب خلينا
نخليك همم تاخذ لك جوله سريعه قبل ما تبدا
مباراه الولايات المتحده وهولندا في كاس
العالم اشكرك جزيل الشكر من فعاليه بسطه
الرياض مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم على كل
هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل الختام الرابعه
وكاله انباء متابعه للقضاء الايراني تقول
بان اعداد قتل الاحتجاجات تجاوز المئتين
شخص
العربيه ترافق سفينه بالاسطول الخامس
الامريكي ضمن مهمه للتصدي لتهريب الاسلحه
والمخدرات
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن عن ترحيل اكثر من
10 الاف مخالف لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال
اسبوع
انطلاق مشروع لزراعه مئه الف شجره في
منتزه عتمر البري بحائل والعام القادم
موعدا للانتهاء اليمن
شكرا لكم على كرم يا لطفي المتابعه نهايه
الرابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]